.
>> ANDERSON, BACK TO YOU.
VAN, WHAT DID YOU THINK OF TIM
SC
SCOTT?
>> HE'S SORT OF THE BIDEN OF HIS
PARTY AND THAT HE COMES ACROSS
WARM AND AUTHENTIC AND HE TELLS
A STORY AND THAT KIND OF IS IT
TRUE.
THE PROBLEM IS NOT THE
MESSENGER.
THE MESSAGE IS NONSENSE.
HE ACTS LIKE ALL THE DIVISIONS
IN THE COUNTRY IS COMING FROM
ONE SIDE.
IT DOES NOT MAKE ANY SENSE.
HE LOST A LOT OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS BY THE TENS OF
MILLIONS WHEN YOU SAY MEASURING
IS NOT A RACIST NATION.
YOU CAN SAY WE ARE GETTING
BETTER BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THESE NUMBERS AND STATISTICS, IT
IS CLEAR THAT THIS COUNTRY IS
STILL STRUGGLING WITH RACISM.
WE STILL HAVE RACISM SHOWING UP
IN EVERY INSTITUTION.
I THOUGHT HE DID HIMSELF A
DISSERVICE BY JUMPING THAT SHARK
UNNECESSARILY.
WITH THAT SAID, THERE IS A
REASON THEY PUT HIM UP.
HE'S THE BEST THEY GOT.
HE CAN GIVE THAT MESSAGE, HE CAN
TALK ABOUT AND POLISH UP ALL THE
REPUBLICAN NONSENSE WITHOUT THE
SHARP EDGES BETTER THAN THE REST
OF THEM.
>> WHAT'S AMAZING IS HOW
DIFFERENT HE SOUNDS FROM ALL THE
OTHER REPUBLICANS.
AGAIN, IT IS ALMOST A TALE THAT
THE REST OF THE PARTY IS IN SUCH
BAD SHAPE THAT YOU GOT TO PUT
HIM UP THERE.
>> HE DID TOUCH A LOT OF THOSE
BIG TOUCH STONE FOR ST
CONSERVATIVES.
I THOUGHT HE PROBABLY SCORED
SOME POINTS FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
ON THE SCHOOL ISSUES.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PARENTS WERE
FRUSTRATED THAT SCHOOLS DID NOT
OPEN QUICKLY.
HE DID SAY AT THE END, ORIGINAL
SIN IS NOT THE END OF OUR STORY.
HE'S ACKNOWLEDGING HISTORY EVEN
AS HE'S MAKING THIS PROCLAMATION
THAT RACISM IS NOT AMERICA.
THIS IS PART OF OUR STORY AND
WHEN PEOPLE ARE SAYING WE NEED
TO CONFRONT IT AND WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND IT.
HE CONFLICTED WITH --
>> WHAT STRUCK ME WAS THIS WAS
NOT A MESSAGE THAT WAS A DONALD
TRUMP MESSAGE AT ALL.
HE WAS NOT SPEAKING TO THE BASE
OF THE PARTY EXCEPT ONE AREA
WHERE HE WAS REFUSING TO GIVE
JOE BIDEN ANY CREDIT ON
COVID-19.
HE SAID THE TIDE HAD ALREADY
TURNED ON COVID-19 WHEN BIDEN
BECAME PRESIDENT AND OF COURSE
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT
OPERATION WARP SPEED HAPPENS
UNDER JOE BIDEN BUT GETTING
VACCINES INTO ARMS WAS A BIDEN
OPERATION.
>> AS YOU SEE HIS EVEOLUTION AS
POLITICIAN, DID IT SURPRISE YOU
OF HIS ABILITY BEING A BIG
TARGET?
>> THERE WAS A THREE-LINE HERE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATIC
RESPONSE THAT JOE BIDEN GAVE IN
1983, HE TALKED ABOUT TWO CORNER
STONES AMERICAN RIGHTS, FAIRNESS
AND OPPORTUNITY.
WHAT I HEARD TONIGHT IN THE JOE
BIDEN'S SPEECH WAS A LOT OF TALK
OF FAIRNESS AND SOME TALK OF
OPPORTUNITY.
THERE IS A LOT OF TALK OF
OPPORTUNITY AND NOT A LOT OF
TALK OF FAIRNESS.
IN SOME WAYS IT MISSES SOMETHING
THAT IT IS CHANGING IN THE
AMERICAN ELECTRIC PARTICULARLY
AMONG THE YOUNG PEOPLE.
>> YOU WENT BACK AND LISTEN TO A
BIDEN RESPOND TO A SPEECH IN
1983.
>> GOOD SATURDAY NIGHT.
>> ONE OF THE GOOD THINGS ABOUT
HAVING A TIM SCOTT IN THE MIX IS
THAT HE'S REACHING OUT AND HE'S
WORKING TO GET SOMETHING DONE ON
THE POLICING STUFF.
IT DOES TAKE SOME COURAGE.
I WANT TO GIVE HIM HIS CREDIT.
HE'S RUNNING FOR REELECTION
SOON.
HE CAN GET PRIMARY IF HE GOES
TOO FAR IN A LIBERAL ELECTION.
HE DOES HAVE THE INTEGRITY TO
SAY THAT I KNOW POLICING IS A
PROBLEM, I DEALT WITH IT AND I
WANT TO WORK ON IT.
DEMOCRATS SHOULD APPLAUD THAT.
I JUST THINK THAT SOME OF THE
OTHER THINGS HE'S TRYING TO
POLISH UP IS CLEAR REPUBLICANS
ARE ATTACKING VOTING RIGHTS.
THEY'RE NOT PASSING A BUNCH OF
BILLS TO TRY TO MAKE VOTING
EASIER.
HIS GENIUS IS WORTHY OF A BETTER
CAUSE AND TRYING TO DEFEND SOME
OF THE STUFF HE'S DOING.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN TALKED ABOUT
BORDERS AND IMMIGRATIONS AND DID
NOT TALK ABOUT A NUMBER OF
REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
CRITICIZING HIM TONIGHT, M FOR
TALKING ABOUT THE BORDER CRISIS
AND SO MANY PEOPLE COMING ACHRIS
CHR
ACROSS THE PAST FEW MONTHS. FES
HIM.
HE HOPES THE DISCUSSION WOULD
SIGNIFY -- HE DID TALK ABOUT
ASSIGNING THE VICE PRESIDENT TO
TRY TO RESOLVE SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE LEADING TO THE
CRISIS.
HE DIDN'T COMPLETELY -- HE
DIDN'T OFFER A SOLUTION
PARTICULARLY TONIGHT BUT YOU
KNOW, AGAIN, JUST GETTING BACK
TO HIS SPEECH.
I REALLY, YOU KNOW, IN SOME WAY
I REGRET THAT HE HAD TO TOUCH
ALL THOSE BASES.
IF IT HAD JUST BEEN ABOUT
ECONOMIC ISSUES HE'S PUSHING, IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE POWERFUL,
NOT THAT THOSE ISSUES, THE OTHER
ISSUES ARE VITALLY IMPORTANT TO
PEOPLE BUT THE ESSENCE OF HIS
SPEECH WAS ECONOMIC SPEECH.
IT WAS STATE OF THE UNION SPEECH
ATTACHED TO AN ECONOMIC SPEECH.
>> THESE THINGS TEND TO BE
LAUNDRY LIST AND FROM BEING IN
THE WHITE HOUSE KINDS OF GETTING
PASSED AROUND.
>> IT IS AWFUL.
>> THE BEGINNING I THINK AND THE
END WAS WHAT BIDEN WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT WHICH IS OUR
DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE.
THE ISSUE I HAVE WITH SCOTT AND
REPUBLICANS RIGHT NOW IS YES,
BIDEN IS PROPOSING ALL THESE
SPENDING AND FIGURING OUT A WAY
TO PAY FOR IT.
REPUBLICANS HAVE NO CREDIBILITY
PAYING FOR
IF ONLY THEY'D PAY FOR THINGS IN
THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
THEY SAY BIGGEST TAX INCREASE,
ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
WELL, THEY HAD ONE.
AND IT COST THE GOVERNMENT WHAT,